pour les usagers du ffa au pierre
lagourgue de l'association apajh et
toute leur équipe de professionnels ce
soir c'est le grand soir l'établissement
fête ses 10 ans et organise pour
l'occasion un gala au théâtre du grand
marché à saint denis pour le f à eau qui
a orienté son projet vers la pratique
des activités artistiques
c'est l'occasion de montrer tout ce
qu'ils ont préparée au cours de leurs
ateliers tout au long de l'année
aujourd'hui on célèbre le dixième
anniversaire de notre établissement
c'est un peu l'aboutissement de notre
projet d'accompagnement dont une des
composantes c'est la pratique
d'activités artistiques le théâtre la
danse la musique le chant et on
travaille toutes les semaines avec nos
résidents qui s'investissent beaucoup à
l'apprentissage de nouvelles techniques
développement de nouvelles compétences
autour du support actions artistiques et
on va de l'écriture jusqu'à la
représentation donc aujourd'hui c'est
effectivement un peu l'aboutissement le
ffa ou a choisi le prestigieux théâtre
du grand marché pour ce gala standing
oblige il s'agit par la même occasion de
rappeler que l'association s'inscrit
dans une démarche d'égalité d'accès aux
lieux culturels
on a le souci en permanence d'investir
la cité est de permettre à nos résidents
d'avoir une vie sociale telle qu'elle
leur revient comme vous et moi et c
en ayant accès à des lieux de culture
comme le théâtre du grand marché et
qu'on peut vraiment jouer cette carte-là
de l'inclusion sociale
les artistes qui accompagne les
personnes porteuses de handicap sont
aussi dans les coulisses pendant la
journée de répétition veut ça fait deux
ans qu'on travaille sur quatre ou cinq
chansons dont le but à la fin ce serait
d'enregistrer un album
et puis préparer une tournée en
métropole
et là ce soir on va faire une
restitution de tout le travail qu'on a
fait depuis deux ans en fait c'est ça ma
contribution ce soir pour les usagers du
ffa ou tu cet univers de la scène c'est
un moment de bonheur très bien banny
cause avait coupé jamais nascar ils
dansent chantent ont fait et canaux déjà
germé dans la tête ça te plait 2
de participer à ce spectacle oui elle
est allée pierre c'est quoique plutôt
dois beaucoup travailler pour ces
spectacles tollé et là tu prêtes
oui comment tu te sens à cet après midi
il termine des deux jours de répétition
avant le lever de rideau
la foule s'amasse devant les portes du
théâtre
le président de l'apajh réunion et parmi
elles et souligne l'importance de cet
événement c'est un anniversaire très
important pourquoi parce que ça a été le
premier établissement de la page réunion
voilà et on sait que le premier dans une
famille est très attendu est celui là
était très attendu à l'époque dans le
cadre des politiques pour les personnes
souffrant d'handicap à la réunion en 99
donc première établissements premiers
projets innovants et on peut dire
maintenant alors que dix ans une grande
réussite
l'événement est de taille pour
l'association et les parents sont fiers
devant leurs enfants montés sur scène
son parti en métropole tout ça ils sont
déjà connus
il est monté sur scène
c'est à béate com
alors en fait ce soir et elle monte pas
sur scène elle est venue voir les autres
puisqu'elle est dans un autre
établissement
mais claire a eu l'occasion en fait de
faire beaucoup de spectacles dans les
établissements où elles étaient
auparavant
et c'est vrai que c'est une autre je
voyais une autre jeune fille quand elle
est face aux spectateurs et qu'elle peut
s'exprimer et un autre moyen en fait de
s'exprimer c'est vraiment une grande
joie de la voir aussi heureux sur scène
à la salle est pleine à craquer
la soirée peut commencer place à la
magie du théâtre